[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi,
and welcome to episode
number 84 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am very well.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good,
enjoying an amazing weather
here in New York.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, good for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm here for QCon.
You are in San Francisco?
MARK MANDEL: I am in
San Francisco, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And, very
excited about today's episode.
We're going to be talking
about-- so we the episode
on big data, on
data sets last week.
And one of the cool things
that you can do with data sets
is you could organize things
like competitions, right?
And that's what Kaggle does.
And we have-- when they can--
a software engineer from Kaggle
that's going to tell us
everything about it, which
is very exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, they do
some really awesome big data
competition, so super
glad to have them
on so we can talk
all about them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and they do have,
also, some awesome,
awesome data sets
that are available for
competitions, but also
to anyone to play with.
So really, really cool.
And then at the end, we'll
have a question about--
I think it was last
week or the week
before, we mentioned
headless Kubernetes services.
And we said that if you
don't know what they mean,
you should go read that
article that we linked to.
So today we have a
question about them--
partly.
It's about Kubernetes and
gRPC, and services and stuffs.
But that will be at
the end of the episode.
But before we start, we have
the cool things of the week.
And we have a bunch
of them today.
Yeah, one of them is kind
of related to an episode
that we did a long time
ago-- episode 72, which
is three months ago already,
or something like that.
It's crazy.
On CRE-- customer
reliability engineering,
we had Luke Stone that
came to tell us about it.
Well, they wrote an article
which is really cool.
It's how SRE find the
landmines in a service.
"CRE Life Lessons,"
which is basically
what we're talking about.
If you become a
customer of CRE--
or more than a
customer, it's almost
like a partner with CRE--
there's going to be some
analysis of what you're doing,
your services, what
are the things that
might cause problems?
And that's exactly what
they cover in this article.
This is a very, very
interesting one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
really like this article.
The particular part
I enjoy is, what
happens when something needs
to be supported by SRE or CRE?
Do I just throw it over the wall
and be like, here you go, it's
yours now?
Or is there some kind of--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Good luck.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
Or is there some kind of
onboarding process or review
or how that gets taken in
as a company that is then
supported by CRE or SRE?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I really like it.
If you have not
read the SRE book,
I definitely recommend it.
This is like a small,
tiny chapter of what
could be part of SRE book.
It is not part of
it, because we're
talking about CRE, which was not
a thing back then when the SRE
book was written.
But still, super interesting.
And really, we like life
lessons and what we actually
do at Google.
So actual work
experience in there.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So for another cool thing
of the week, finally--
it took a while coming-- but
we do support Java, right?
On Google Earth Engine.
That's a round of
applause kind of moment.
It's been something people--
a few people have asked for it.
It's just a couple
here or there.
No, it's been a
long time coming,
and I'm very happy
to see it there.
The other thing I want--
I feel like it's buried
lead, a little bit--
but we're talking about
basically fully supporting
off-the-shelf frameworks
such as Spring Boot,
but also alternative languages
like Kotlin, Apache Groovy.
Basically anything you can
turn into a [INAUDIBLE]
through Maven or Gradle.
So that's actually
pretty exciting, too.
I've played a lot with
alternative JVM languages,
and I like them a lot.
So I'm super happy to see
that support getting baked in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, and as my job
is to be a little bit
of a troll against Java,
I will say that finally
Java is getting lambdas--
or some definition of lambda.
Anyway, also, we
have something else
which is related to App Engine.
We finally have go on the rate
on App Engine, as beta for now.
But will be available-- so it
is available with Go App now.
If you use Go App,
you know what it is.
GCloud will be
supported very soon.
Probably by the time
this episode comes out,
we will be supported.
But maybe takes a couple
days more so, yeah.
Check it out.
And it will be beta
for a little bit.
You can try it, give it a try.
It should work, because Go
is backwards compatible.
But it's definitely worth
trying and filing any issues,
if you find any.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And last, I think, but
definitely not least,
is a wonderfully
hilarious thing.
So if anyone is a fan or a
viewer of "Silicon Valley,"
you may recognize the
Not Hotdog application
that was made by one of
its characters on the show.
This is an article
that talks about how
this was built with TensorFlow,
Keras, and React Native.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is an actual thing.
I think it's pretty amazing
that "Silicon Valley"-- not
only they take actual
people from Silicon Valley
to give them advice, but also
they use the same products.
And they actually
develop the prototypes
of the apps they show.
So it's kind of amazing.
I really, really like it.
It makes me want to
watch the show more.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no,
it's super, super cool.
And you can see,
basically, everything
they learn about how
they could make it
so that you could either
recognize that something's
a hot dog or not a hot dog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it is.
And the thing is
that, yeah, you could
write that up if you want to.
If you are a huge fan
of "Silicon Valley"
and you want to be part of the
thing, yeah, write the code
and try it.
It is actually not that
hard with TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: And it should
be pointed out-- if you want,
you can download the app
from either iOS or Android.
It is available.
So if you ever need to
know what's not a hot dog
or is a hot dog,
you can do that now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I really like--
there's someone that
actually downloaded the app
and took a picture
of his forearm
with some ketchup on top.
And the app says
it is a hot dog.
Also, a banana with ketchup
on top, and it's also hot dog.
And even an apple
with ketchup on top.
So apparently, it
had been optimized
for detecting ketchup.
If there's ketchup,
it's a hot dog.
You need to maybe retrain
a little bit, the model,
to make sure it recognizes
better in this case.
It's pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
speaking of deep learning,
why don't we go have a chat
with Wendy from Kaggle?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds
good, let's do that.
So I am very, very happy to
have today Wendy Kan, a data
scientist from Kaggle.
They joined Google
not that long ago,
and we are very
happy to welcome you.
How are you doing?
WENDY KAN: Good, thanks
for inviting me here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you for taking the time
to talk a little
bit about Kaggle
and all the cool things
you can do with it.
Before we start
talking about Kaggle,
tell us a little bit
about who you are
and what you do at Google.
WENDY KAN: Sounds good.
I'm a data scientist at Kaggle.
I work with companies or
organizations or research
groups on the machine
learning problems
that they want to solve.
I give them advice of what
they should do to their data
and how to form that into a
suitable competition design,
present them to our
Kaggle community,
and for people to
solve the problem.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so you mentioned
competition design,
which bridges really
well to what Kaggle does.
Tell us a little bit--
what is Kaggle and why do
people like it so much?
WENDY KAN: Yeah, Kaggle is a
community of data scientists.
We're a platform and
we're a community,
and we have all sorts of things
that surround the community.
We're best known for
our competitions,
and most people know us
from the competitions.
We also have a very
strong product--
that's Kaggle Kernels--
that people love to use.
We also have a data set
platform that people
share open data set on Kaggle.
So we're really, really
close to a million users now.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, so you
mentioned three things there--
data sets, kernels,
and competitions.
Why don't we break those down?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Actually, competitions--
I think that the first
time I heard about Kaggle
was when we did that
announcement about the YouTube
contest.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was an Kaggle, right?
WENDY KAN: Yeah,
that's my project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, nice!
That is awesome.
Yeah, we used it as a
cool thing of the week.
I don't know if anyone from
the podcast participated,
but it sounded like a
really good opportunity
to try cool things
with data science.
WENDY KAN: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
let's talk a little bit
about competitions.
For instance, what
is a competition?
How does that work?
WENDY KAN: We run all
sorts of competitions.
We're a very small team,
so the benefit of that is I
get to touch all
sorts of projects.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How small is small?
WENDY KAN: When
we were acquired,
I think we were 15 people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's small, yeah.
WENDY KAN: Yeah, we
have two data scientists
doing competition design.
So there's not really, like,
what kind of competitions
I run--
we run everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You
do all of the things.
WENDY KAN: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah, what's
an example of a competition?
I know we've mentioned
the YouTube one, but--
WENDY KAN: So I just
launched one this week.
It's a million dollar
prize Zillow competition.
It's going to be
predicting house prices.
That's very exciting.
Everybody has a lot
of ideas about how
to improve their
house prediction,
and Zestimate has been
a big thing that people
talk about and use a lot.
And we want to have a
competition for people
to basically just see
how hard the problem is.
And maybe it's easy, and
somebody can solve it better
than Zestimate, and
that would be great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
was laughing about it,
because I'm going through
the Coursera course
on machine learning, and
actually, the first example
ever is how to predict
house prices given--
WENDY KAN: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --that
is very interesting.
That still goes on even when
you become a professional
and you're doing competitions,
still the same problem.
MARK MANDEL: Still
the same problem.
WENDY KAN: It is very
exciting, because it
is the machine learning 101 or
stats 101 problem that people
want to solve.
We actually had to jump
through a lot of hoops,
in terms of getting the data and
having the license to release
the data.
So it's not that easy
to get it running,
but it's very exciting.
And we feel like our
community will love it a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, so from
a developer perspective--
I want to go do
this competition.
What's my process
for doing that?
And then, what's my end result?
How do you determine
whether I win or I lose?
WENDY KAN: For a normal
Kaggle competition--
the Zillow one is a
particular example,
and I'll go into that later.
But for a normal
Kaggle competition,
you download the data
from a Kaggle site,
or you don't download the
data and use Kaggle Kernels
and just do online analysis and
use your browser and everything
is run on the Cloud.
And then you can basically
read through the documentation
that we provide, or just
have fun and explore the data
itself on the Cloud.
For the competitions, there's
always a column or property
that you are going to
predict, and there is always
going to be a metric
that calculates
how well you're predicting
against the ground
truth-- the answer.
And you basically submit a bunch
of predictions in the CSV file,
and we'll give you a score.
And that score puts
you on the leaderboard,
and you can see that there are
a lot of people ahead of you.
You will want to
improve your score
and beat these people
in front of you.
One thing to note is that to do
good machine learning practice,
we have a public and
private leaderboard
to prevent people
from overfitting.
Because when you
keep predicting,
you're going to overfit your
model, even if you're not
trying to just cheat.
Your model will overfit
to the ground truth.
So we ask people to predict
a bunch of predictions,
and only some of that go
into the public leaderboard
that people can get feedback
on and instantly improve
their models.
But the final results
are determined
from a private
leaderboard where people
don't get the score right
away, and that's revealed
at the end of a competition.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so that's
like when you're doing machine
learning, you have the
training set and then the test
set and the validation set--
WENDY KAN: That's exactly it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're
actually exposing
the training and the test,
but not the validation.
WENDY KAN: Exactly.
We give people the
training, and the validation
is equivalent to the
public leaderboard
and the holdout
set is equivalent
to the private leaderboard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK, cool.
MARK MANDEL: And
for those people
who don't know what overfitting
is, what's overfitting?
WENDY KAN: That's when your
model is learning things
that it's not supposed to know.
So basically, if there's
particular things in this data
set that is not representative
of the population,
and your model
basically overfits
to the characteristics of this
particular sample of the data.
And that's an overfit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The way I learned
that-- which, I think
is pretty cool--
is imagine that you
have a bunch of points.
If you have more
parameters than points,
you can actually
draw a line that
goes every single one
of the points, which
doesn't make any sense.
But has 100% accuracy
for the data.
MARK MANDEL: For
exactly that data set.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But if
you give any other data,
it would be completely wrong.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
WENDY KAN: If you use a house
price prediction example,
it'll be like, oh, this house
is $3 million and it has--
I don't know-- a
door that's broken.
And so your model learns
that, and then predicts
if you have a broken door,
then it's $3 million,
and that's not the case
for all the houses.
But that's unfortunately
the sample that you pick.
MARK MANDEL: All right, and
two-- outside of competitions,
you also host data sets?
Is that together or separate, or
what's the relationship there?
It It is a separate
offering, and that part
is relatively new on Kaggle.
So we host open
data sets on Kaggle,
because we feel like
Kaggle Kernels is a very
strong tool for people to use.
And hosting these
public data sets
lets people explore
these data sets
and share their
findings on Kaggle.
And also, it's just
for public good.
We've all been there
to look for a data set,
and you're just randomly
searching on the internet,
and then you feel like that's
available and you can't--
it's a good place to find
all sorts of data sets.
And now it's pretty organic.
So far, we publish some,
and then the community
will publish some.
And a lot of times, we're
surprised that this data
set is here, and it's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So does
that mean that I can use it
for whatever I want to do?
Let's say I'm learning
machine learning, right?
Can I go and play with
any of those data sets?
WENDY KAN: Yep, correct,
you can do that.
It's not just for
machine learning, right?
You could do anything.
You could do
exploratory analysis
that's not predicting
anything on those data sets.
So it's a wide range.
It ranges from how
ISIS uses Twitter
or the Pokemon
statistics data set,
or we found the "Bachelorette"
and the "Bachelor" data
set on it.
So yeah, so it's pretty cool.
And now, even if I just
want to find some example,
if I want to make a demo
to somebody very quickly,
I'll go and look for some
new data sets to show off.
MARK MANDEL: And
these data sets,
they can be submitted
by anybody, or?
WENDY KAN: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: So they're
community-powered.
That's really cool.
So we keep mentioning kernels,
but we should probably
talk about exactly
what that is, because I
think it's actually super, super
cool when I had a look at it.
WENDY KAN: So
Kaggle Kernels has--
I think we launched it
maybe two years ago?
You go to Kaggle.com/Kernels.
It's very simple.
It takes care of
basically everything
that a data scientist
needs for very quickly run
some code to analyze data.
So you click open a
notebook, or open a code,
and it pops up in
your browser, and you
start editing your code.
And the data is
there depending on--
if you're in a competition,
then the competition's data
is all in there.
If you're in a data set, the
data set's data's all there.
So as a data scientist, before,
a lot of times you go in
and you receive a new data set,
and you want to explore it.
If you don't have a computer
that you have already set up,
spending hours and hours
of installing packages,
then you're going to
spend hours doing that.
But for this one, also
uses a Docker image,
and that's community maintained.
So most of the packages
that people want to use
are already in there.
So it's pretty convenient.
It's also a great place
to show off your work
and to benefit from
other people's work.
Usually when you run it,
it already becomes public,
so people can see it.
So if you want to say, I
have this new text data set
and I want to see what
other people do with it,
and then you read other
people's notebook.
And they already did
this amazing analysis.
And you can be like, oh, I
have this new idea that they
can extend from.
Then it's just like GitHub
where you can fork it,
and then you can
make a new version.
With that, you still don't
have to download any code
on your computer.
It's just all
stays on the Cloud,
and you only need the
browser to do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so you have
all of these big data sets, and
people can provide data sets.
Then you also have these
analyses like the kernels,
where people can provide code
that you run on that data set.
And all of these
runs on the Cloud.
Who pays for this?
Do you need to pay for
it, or how does this work?
WENDY KAN: So right now
Kaggle pays for all of that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
WENDY KAN: Of course,
because it's a free product,
we have a limit on people--
how long you can run the code
for, and there is a memory
limit.
In the future, we definitely--
probably after the integration
with GCP is complete--
we'll see if there is a way to
let people to customize what
they want to try to run in.
For example, there is
a lot of network stuff
that needs to be run on
GPU for it to be fast.
Right now, we don't
have that capability.
We know that GCP
has it, but we'll
need to enable that and
then see where it goes.
So that part is an unknown.
But so far, we have a pretty
widely-used interface, and then
a community that's
using it very actively.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'd
love to actually interview
the team again once you have
finished the migration to GCP,
and see like if you using TPUs
or GPUs and all that stuff.
That'd be a very
interesting episode.
WENDY KAN: Definitely.
MARK MANDEL: So yeah,
that's a really great segue
into-- so recently--
a few weeks, months?
Something like that-- you
were acquired by Google Cloud.
What does that mean for Kaggle?
I mean, you talk a
little bit about moving
to our infrastructure, is there
anything else you can discuss?
WENDY KAN: The
acquisition definitely
is a big change for our lives.
We moved over to Google offices
and are using Google computers.
We are still operating
as an independent brand.
We kept our Kaggle emails.
We have our site,
and we are still
mainly focused on growing
the Kaggle community.
And we want to bring the
best content and best product
to our users.
So that still doesn't change.
That's still always
our goal, and we
want to bring the
best to our community.
The change for Kaggle and
GCP integration is upcoming,
and it's probably not going to
be very obvious to our users,
because it's going to
be in the back end.
Right now, the community knows
that Kaggle is run on Azure.
A lot of codebase
are based on C#.
So that's a big challenge
to move over to GCP,
and we're definitely
investigating
on what can be done and
what needs to be done.
So it's going to
be a slow process.
It's not going to be
anything fast, and it's not--
of course, the main focus is
we want to grow our community.
So the integration
is second, and we
believe that it'll be the
best for our community,
because of Google's
infrastructure
and the powerful compute.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so I
guess since you mentioned C#,
[INAUDIBLE] about.
So most people that do
machine learning nowadays,
they use Python
and some libraries.
One of those libraries
is TensorFlow.
Is TensorFlow something that
you can use on top of Kaggle?
Is that the only
thing you can use?
I'm assuming not, since
you're mentioning C#.
How does that work?
What libraries can
I use on a kernel?
WENDY KAN: Yeah, just
a clarification--
the C# is what the
site is run on.
So the site doesn't have--
can't really say it doesn't
have Python, but is--
majority isn't C#.
There's--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
Python hiding everywhere.
WENDY KAN: --maybe-- right.
But our Kaggle Kernels--
what the data scientists
would use and what I use,
are Python and R. So in
Kaggle Kernels, there's no C#,
obviously.
So, yeah, talking about
TensorFlow and the frameworks,
it's a good question.
TensorFlow is available
on Kaggle Kernels.
Not because of the
acquisition, it's
just because it's
a popular framework
for people to use neural
network on, and now
a lot of other things.
It's a great framework, and it's
getting a really great momentum
for people, especially
that Keras has always
been a community favorite
for deep learning framework,
and now Keras has switched to
using TensorFlow as back end.
So it's becoming more
powerful and that
has been a favorite for Kaggle.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You mentioned Keras.
What is Keras?
WENDY KAN: Keras is a
higher-level framework
for using deep learning.
It's great that
people love to use it,
because you don't have to worry
about a lot of the detailed set
up.
You could say, I
want to layer this
and I want a model
of this shape,
and it's very easy to use.
And what's great
about it is that it
can connect to different
frameworks on the lower level,
too.
So it's very heavily used
by Kaggle communities.
And you'll see a lot of Keras
usage on Kaggle Kernels,
and just generally,
people use it a lot.
And I know the author--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How
do you write Keras?
WENDY KAN: How do you write--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How do you write it?
If I want to search it?
Because I would
say C-A-R-R-O-S--
Keras?
WENDY KAN: Oh!
It's K-E-R-A-S.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, OK.
Just in case someone
wants to search it.
WENDY KAN: And the author,
actually, is now at Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sorry?
WENDY KAN: The author
is now at Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, nice.
WENDY KAN: Yeah.
So that's the
TensorFlow integration.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
on top of TensorFlow, then,
you can also use
all the libraries.
If you want to use--
I actually don't know
of any other library
other than TensorFlow
[INAUDIBLE],,
but I'm sure there is.
WENDY KAN: There are.
Kaggle wants to remain very
neutral on these tools.
We want people to use whatever
tools that they prefer.
So we don't specify.
We don't push for
people to use anything,
because people should
feel free to use
whatever they want to use.
And I mentioned Keras.
There's also great
frameworks like Caffe
that people use a lot.
And these days, a lot of
people start to use Pi Torch.
Definitely a lot of
different frameworks
that people prefer to use.
And generally, we
just love to have
a diversity of different
frameworks on our site.
And I know our
community was concerned
when we got acquired that we
were going to heavily push
TensorFlow or stuff like that.
And it's definitely not
our position to do that,
because we feel like we're
just-- we're a platform.
We want people to use the best
tools that suit their needs,
and we give content and
people choose their tools,
and we'll support them.
MARK MANDEL: So
really it's about just
providing the underlying
infrastructure to them
as they need it.
So GPUs or bigger memory
sizes or anything else
that they can take advantage of.
WENDY KAN: Exactly.
I do feel very excited about
TensorFlow for my own use.
Kaggle has always been-- we
have these competition sponsors,
and they're looking
for a solution,
and the community would provide
them with a great solution.
But over the years, it's
always been a disconnect
between the prototype that
the Kaggle community provides
and what they can actually
put in production.
So a lot of times, first
it's heavily ensembled,
which means just a lot
of different models
are put together,
averaged, and it's not
very production-friendly.
And I'm hoping that
with TensorFlow--
I know how Google's investing
a lot of infrastructure
on making these things
production-ready.
And hopefully these
will make the transition
between the prototyping and
the production work easier.
And that would be a great
benefit for our customers
and for the community
too, because you're
doing all these
fun work on Kaggle
and then if you don't have to--
if it's not another
tough project
to put it in production,
then it'd be awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so just go
a little bit over all
the things we went over.
So Kaggle has data sets,
and those data sets
are allowed for-- anyone can
contribute new data sets,
and you can use them
for whatever you want.
You can download them and
train them by yourself
if you want to?
WENDY KAN: That's correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You also have
kernels, which is basically
scripts that you're going to
be using to train some models.
WENDY KAN: Correct.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And again,
anyone can go and see them
and you can participate,
in term like forking them
and improving them or whatever.
WENDY KAN: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then on top
of that, you have competitions.
WENDY KAN: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Can you
also contribute competitions?
WENDY KAN: Yeah, definitely.
So we have been working with--
this competition's
almost coming to an end,
that you guys have announced it.
It's the YouTube competition.
Anyone can propose
a competition to us,
and we'll definitely
talk to people.
You have to have the data.
You have to have
a problem in mind.
A lot of my work is
talking to people
and understand what
they want to solve.
They have an idea, and
then they have a data set.
And a lot of times,
the data set really
doesn't solve the problem.
So I could brainstorm with them.
Well, your data set is about--
I don't know-- peoples'
bank activities,
and you want to
predict climate change,
and it's not really related.
But you can probably
predict if this person's
going to go to a bank and open
a checking account, things
like that.
We provide that service.
And then we select things that
are helpful and are interesting
and are meaningful to our
users, and hopefully gets--
it lets people to touch data
and problems that they normally
don't have the
opportunity to touch
in their normal, daily
lives, and to try new things.
So that's very exciting.
The other thing that's
exciting about--
I was talking about the YouTube
competition-- is that normally
in the past, for
Kaggle users, we
have smaller data sets and
smaller computing power.
And this one, we're
using Google Cloud
and it's a large data
set that people normally
don't have access to.
I think it's 7 million
videos or something.
And--
MARK MANDEL: I remember that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I remember
there was like 8 million.
The contest is
YouTube 8 million,
but then there's
8 million videos.
MARK MANDEL: There's
7 million videos.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
WENDY KAN: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, which is--
OK.
MARK MANDEL: Because there's
1 million training data?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 7 million
is the training data,
and I think that 1 million is
the validation of some data.
MARK MANDEL: You would
know, it's your competition.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
WENDY KAN: I think
the story is actually
they released a first version
of the YouTube 8 million,
and-- oh, that's one thing
that is special about Kaggle
competitions.
Is that if it's a
publicly-available data,
then people know the
answer to the competition.
Then we can't run
that competition.
If it's already public, can't
ask people not to cheat.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What do you
mean, if they know the answer?
WENDY KAN: So for
example, if we ask
people to predict the
presidential election of 2016--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, I see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, OK, yeah.
Predicting things in the
past tends to be easier.
WENDY KAN: Right, exactly.
So they had to
analyze new videos
and release these
with Kaggle, and then
hide some of the
labels for us in order
to make the competition fair.
So that's the 7 million.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice, well,
we're running out of time.
I am super excited.
As I said, I'm learning a
little bit of machine learning,
and it feels like Kaggle
is the perfect place
to keep on learning more and
play with a bunch of data.
Is there anything else
that you'd like to mention?
Something that we
might have missed?
WENDY KAN: Yeah, join
our Zillow competition.
It's the biggest prize ever.
It's a very--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's a lot if money.
WENDY KAN: Yep.
It's enough money for
you to buy a house.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe
not in San Francisco.
WENDY KAN: Maybe a studio.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Small
house with a broken door.
WENDY KAN: Join
that competition.
And we're also very
excited that we're
going to welcome our
million user very soon.
So yeah, so Kaggle's doing well.
And we definitely
hope more people
will join Kaggle
and start exploring
and learn data science with
us, with the big community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So thank you so
much to Wendy Kan for spending
her time explaining a little
bit about what Kaggle is and all
the cool data sets
that they have,
the amazing competitions,
and how you can make money
by being a data scientist.
Pretty good experience.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it looks like
a really great way for people
to get together and
collaboratively work
on machine learning
projects using
big data, which is super cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it really feels
like it's the kind of thing
that if you're a student,
you should definitely try,
because at worst you're
learning, and at best
you're making money.
So I'd say go for it.
And I think it's time to go
for our question of the week.
The question of the
week, I'm going to ask it
because the answer is--
I think you're going to
probably give it better than me.
But it's-- OK, I want to do
client side load balancing with
gRPC and Kubernetes.
So if you have a
Kubernetes service,
what you get from
the service normally
is one IP, which is virtual
IP, that you send your requests
there and it's done.
Somehow it gets load
balanced to a bunch
of pods that are behind.
But the problem is
that as long as you
keep one connection
with gRPC, you
will send all of your requests
all the time to the same pod,
until that pod restarts.
And then you will send
it to someone else.
But what if I want to actually
distribute that load across all
of the pods that are available?
How do I do that
from the client?
MARK MANDEL: So yeah,
this is a fun problem,
and something that's been
talked about a lot in gRPC.
I'm sure you can find
lots of threads on it.
The basic answer for
gRPC is-- what you often
do is what's called client
side load balancing.
So basically, you feed
a series of IP addresses
to your gRPC client,
then you tell it
how you want to load balance it.
So Round-robin, right?
Does one then the other, and
then the other, then the other,
then goes back around again.
So the fun question
becomes, how do I
get all those IP addresses?
How do I tell it the 4, 5,
15 IP addresses and ports
that it needs to
know to connect to
and then can then subsequently
send and distribute
those requests across
those IP addresses?
So inside Kubernetes,
there's a couple
of nice ways of doing it.
We'll link in the show
notes to a GitHub repository
that one of our other
teammates [INAUDIBLE] started.
This is a Java example,
because I know Francesc
is all about that all the time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I love Java.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
We chose two different ways.
So one way is using
DNS service discovery,
which is a built-in tool
kit that comes with gRPC.
So-- last week, I want to
say, or several weeks ago,
I can't remember now--
we talked about headless
services in Kubernetes.
So what those end up being is
rather than having a single DNS
entry that does a load balance
itself, like a server-side load
balancer that points out to all
these pods behind it, what it
actually has is a DNS entry but
with multiple A records, each
with an A record
that points to the IP
address of the various
running instances behind it.
So basically, you
can hit that DNS
and be like, hey, give
me all your A records,
and that gives you the catalog
of all the pods behind so you
can get access to all of
those running instances
and know their IP addresses
and connect to them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
then, if I am the client,
then I get the list and I can
go over all of the IP addresses
in that list.
But what if I have many clients?
MARK MANDEL: Do you
have many clients?
That's fine, you can do
that for every client that
ends up connecting.
That's totally cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And what's great
is gRPC comes with a DNS name
resolver middleware that you can
just drop in that understands,
oh, if you have multiple A
records on this DNS record,
then I know that I should be
Round-robin-ing around those.
So I should be load
balancing across those
given a certain strategy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and on top of that, also--
Kubernetes will rotate the order
of the IPs every single time
you get the DNS.
So if you get a bunch of
different clients connecting
to the DNS, you will
actually end up hitting--
by default-- to some kind of
Round-robin [INAUDIBLE] list,
some kind of load
balancing, automatically,
on top of the load balancing
that you might want to do,
which is pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: That
is really cool.
Now, there's another
way you can also do it,
which is neat as well.
And Ray gives us another
example of that, wherein
you can query the Kubernetes
API service discovery-- so it's
got a whole API in there
where it's like, hey,
would you like to tell
me all the IP addresses?
So rather than
going through DNS,
you can do it through
that way as well.
So there's a couple
of different ways
you can do it as you
need to, depending
on your wants and/or needs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I wrote a
little code doing exactly that,
using the API--
the Kubernetes API.
But rather than querying
the Kubernetes API
every time, what I did was
I had a little side guard
that actually got notifications
from the Kubernetes API,
because you can watch something.
So you watch the list of IPs
and every single time there's
a new pod or a pod
that disappears,
you are automatically notified.
So whenever you want
to send a request,
you already have the list,
which makes it faster.
So yeah, lots of really cool
ways to do the same thing.
Really, go with the one that
works better for your workflow.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
All right, well
before we finish up--
I know you're at QCon right now,
but what have you got going on,
Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yes,
I am at QCon right now.
By the time this
episode will be out,
I will be back to San
Francisco-- hopefully.
And right after that, I will
be out to GopherCon in Denver.
Very excited about
that, I'm going
to be running a
couple of workshops.
So it's going to
be pretty intense.
Looking forward to meeting
all of my dear gophers
from all around the world.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Well, I'm not
going anywhere for a little bit.
But in July, I will be in
New York for the Google Cloud
Summit.
I'll be there presenting
with Phoenix1 games.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice,
that sounds really fun.
What day is it?
MARK MANDEL: It is
the 18th of July.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
I will not be there.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm actually taking that
week off completely.
So while you enjoy New York, I
will be enjoying some holidays.
MARK MANDEL: Very
nice, very nice.
Well, Francesc, thank
you again for joining me
for yet another episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]